what we're doing here today is we're
delivering declarations to the Secretary
of State to the Senate Pro Tem and to
the assembly Pro Tem for the purpose of
withdrawal for three more counties to
withdraw from state of California and
form the state of Jefferson it's
important because we're engaged in an
article for section three state split in
California because the third of Northern
California has no effective
representation we feel we're being used
to help support the state of California
through our tax dollars that money's
going into the general fund and we're
not seeing any of its we need 10 or 12
counties to be financially viable we
have two votes that will come up in
January and early February so that's
going to be eight counties we have
another declaration we still need to
record Sutter County we just didn't
complete the paperwork in time and then
we have votes coming up in Lake County
and we have town hall meetings coming up
in six or eight other counties so this
is building every single day people
demand Liberty they demand
representation and we're going to get it
after today we would like the state of
California to agree with us the
legislature and let us separate that
would be the ideal situation and then it
would have to go to the US House and
Senate to be approved we have no choice
Northern California has six total state
legislators the County of Los Angeles
alone has thirty five if we don't do
this our economy will collapse our
children will leave we'll all be broken
we'll all be gone I would say that
basically I think everyone wants Liberty
I don't think it's an issue of democrat
or republican or libertarian or
independent I think it's an issue of
representation